hey guys it's Justine and today we're
doing a follow up to the iPad Mini this
is the week with iPad Mini video and
honestly at this point has probably been
a little bit over a week but it's okay
who's counting I know you are I have
been loving this so much I've been
watching movies I've been watching shows
I've been watching Netflix I've also
just been kind of like doing email and
like text messages and stuff like that I
still sometimes do wish that they would
have done an updated design but the
thing is this has been a consistent
design for the past several years so all
of those accessories all of the cases
all of these sort of point-of-sale
things to that like businesses use it
can still use those with this so I think
that's one of the things that a lot of
people have sort of been forgetting
people are using these four different
things not just content consuming
devices so being able to still use the
things that they have been using for
years but getting an updated device I
think is really crucial also the price
point having something that isn't as
crazy expensive as the iPad pro but
still have the functionality and be able
to use the Apple pencil is also
incredible of course I'm not an
illustrator I mean I can use Photoshop
and it's still a designer but as far as
drawing and things like that it's
definitely not something that I'm good
at but I have been enjoying using
procreate and just kind of like doodling
and drawing and just having fun look
this is beautiful this is a work of art
another thing that I like about the iPad
Mini is just being able to take it with
me like basically everywhere no I was
joking about being able to put this in
my yoga pants but it actually does fit
in my yoga pants pocket also I was using
this to fly my drone which is kind of
crazy so being able to have a bigger
screen to be able to see where I'm
flying at amazing you do have to get an
additional adapter to be able to use
this on any of your drones but it's
definitely worth checking out if you do
want to have a bigger screen speaking of
drone flying and bigger screen I got one
of the DJI smart controllers so I'm so
excited to test that out so stay tuned
for that video like I was saying before
the Apple pencil support is one of the
biggest things in the new iPad Mini and
in the iPad air I really want to give
you guys a demonstration on how
illustrators and designers are using
this I can't really draw at all so I am
going to bring in someone who can okay
see it's going to be
like magic ready we've been talking
about the week with iPad and you guys
might remember Corey say hi to my
friends hello friends
you were in my iPad Pro video and since
then you got your own iPad pro that
problem your did and you launched a line
of greeting cards I did of which you've
drawn all of those illustrations on the
iPad everyone I've almost drawn on the
iPad that's really cool let's see them
these are printed versions how cute if a
pelican so can you Jenna actually she I
share one of those cards you can scheme
with she didn't get it or walking it's
for a few minutes I like the little
Buffalo well I branded the car coming
here on the Buffalo it's called lonely
buffalo Press how cute yeah you love it
it's fun do you have the illustrations
on your iPad I do actually yeah well
here's a new one
yours coziest sweater weather that's
cool so that wouldn't be coming out soon
that seems like it's a nice holiday
here's an apology card that I'm working
on it's not you it's me
here's the Buffalo and the roaming gnome
procreate is so incredible does that we
used to do I use procreate you can build
layers here you can get in real close in
detail so I had Corey back here to do
another illustration on the iPad Mini so
as you guys know now all the iPads work
with the Apple pencil now the iPad Mini
and the iPad air only work with the
first generation iPad pencil and the
reason for that is because they're still
using the old design the new Apple
pencil charges magnetically yes it's so
much better
such a great design so this one still
charges the old way which is you put it
in the bottom here it's incredibly
awkward it is it's super silly but they
did come out with that that little
add-on over there I wanted to show you
guys this is really cool I completely
missed this in the unboxing I don't know
who's going through to make sure I
didn't throw anything else away I found
this it comes with an extra tip and it
also comes with this little dongle here
so you can plug the Apple pencil into
the doll rule and then you can actually
have a cord that goes into it so you
don't have to use your iPad to charge
I'd rather have a cord hanging off than
to walk around especially with the other
iPad with the thing sticking out when
you have to
charge so you are working on
illustration you haven't showed it to me
yet that's good to know so it's working
on a new greeting card idea right now
the seasons Mother's Day coming up so I
work on a new greeting card others I
mean you can look at it this is so cute
mama always be here technical support oh
my god I love it
that's not my mom that's more
grandmotherly but yeah you know it works
for the cake factor my groom also
tech-savvy like half the time she's
telling me how to fix things it's crazy
I love it like a little polka dot outfit
so how long do one of these usually take
you so if you're in procreate and go to
video and then you can hit time lapse
replay and it'll show the replay you can
see me kind of sketching here figuring
out what the character is gonna look
like the great thing about working in
layers you can constantly change colors
or bounce stuff around move things this
probably took me four hours maybe it's
really hard for me to pick up background
a lot of greeting cards are just pretty
much a stark white and so I'm not sure
if we're gonna go with purple on this
one but so far I like it
guys what color do you think that you
should make the background you should
let them decide would you suppose a blue
haze but then you have a lot of new
cards right it is a problem blue as you
can tell well that yellow actually see
what I like oh my gosh there's so many
good that's not a good one using
appropriate on here coming from the iPad
pro what were the main differences for
you um this wonderfully fits right in
here very simple yeah I've had brewery
fish since I've switched to the iPad pro
it does not fit in there so that's a
nice thing as the portability if you
carry a smaller stature or smaller bag
you can just slip that guy in there I
also like it for just like when I carry
a moleskin around for a quick sketches
of poetry or whatever I see yeah let me
get out my well that's how a lot of my
poetry and writing stars is just with
the pencil or pen in a little moleskin
and so this is akin to that where I
could just pop this out do a quick
sketch if I see a building I like or a
tree or something that catches my eye
and you can take a picture of it too
do what to draw it you could do both you
could I mean whatever eat some what
accent do that whatever you want to do
I'm shocked at how much I really like
this video I think I unbox one of these
think it was like 2015 I was joking that
it was like the size of the phone and it
all seems dopey but this could honestly
pass it's like apples next phone so
since you've been using the new iPad pro
and the new pencil what are the main
differences for you when using the
different pencils oh my goodness just to
start with the feel of this is so much
more like a regular artists utensil just
like the polish the matte finish to the
polish finish here is so much better to
use this I haven't gotten completely
into the gestures yet because there are
different things you can remap them to
but I'm not yeah I'm not sure I haven't
done that at all because clearly I'm not
an artist so I just kind of am drawing
for fun but if I were to pick which
pencil I thought looked better like I
think this one looks better maybe that
was rose gold oh my gosh
you kind of engraving right this is
great so if anybody's like you stole my
Apple pencil I'd be like knew my names
on it I also got the engraved iPods
iPods oh my gosh air pawn but I got it
engraved it with iJustine because you
can put a lowercase on the pencil you
couldn't use lowercase so I got justine
because a capital i' in front of justine
just looks like i'll just seen and it's
not cool
another thing that I liked about the new
iPad Mini is I'm sure you probably
haven't tried this yet but you can sync
up a bluetooth keyboard to I don't know
I haven't yes you can just go like this
hook up a bluetooth keyboard and type
away show us some more of your drawings
all right sure what something cool how
cute this one is this is my favorite one
by far always want to be an astronaut
when I was a kid I wouldn't be an
astronaut too but they told me through
my eyesight wasn't good enough and then
basically crushed my dreams so here we
are
do you have a greeting card as well this
will be out very soon in the next print
run yeah it was always like well maybe I
can change my contacts in space but I
don't think that trying to put it
through my mask but at least you could
find a contact if it dropped in space
automatic
because it wouldn't drop and he wouldn't
be like nobody-nobody step on it because
it would just be floating what be
floating but then I could just like
stick to something so it would just
float up and probably stick to the
ceiling I've done zero gravity before so
if you like lost it and then it just had
a slight bit of dominoes yes okay keep
going until it hit something well thanks
so much for hanging out with us
that's for having all of his links in
the description below check out your
greeting cards and your Instagram and
your fine art Instagram - which I'm a
huge fan of Sundays on basil so I'll put
all the links below thanks thanks bye
I'm gonna go so my iPad now being able
to connect a bluetooth keyboard to this
thing is also really cool so I've been
using this little stand it's really cute
I put my little iPad right here I'll
turn this here so you guys can see it
have you seen anything more impressive
look how fast like typing nonsensical
letters and this is just one of the ones
that they came with my old iMac it looks
like a tiny little iMac but kind of cute
so this is the little adapter that we
were just talking about and I haven't
got to try this out yet so let's open it
up what a great idea so this just plugs
in just like that it's basically a
lightning to Lightning dongle and then
you can plug in another cable just like
so and then you can charge your pencil
like this this looks like a little
fishing pole like I'd be going fishing I
feel like this is a much better option
than sticking it into your iPad but if
you don't have a cable or this dongle
obviously that works too well guys thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video I've really been
loving the iPad Mini also a huge thank
you to Corey for being in my video and
doing an illustration on the iPad Mini
for me if you guys want to check out his
instagrams I'll put all of his links
below but you can check them out at
Corey basil lonely Buffalo press and
Mazal I'll see you in my next video
[Music]